[Music]
tonight
[Music]
I've been around a long time an
exclusive sit down with a living legend
you never really know what's going to
happen in your career and you hope you
do well Dolly Parton on her six
decade-long career and how she keeps
things naughty and nice with her husband
of 56 years plus is Dolly coming from
Mariah's queen of Christmas Crown
Never Say Never And I have a few tattoos
Dolly bus some of the most outrageous
rumors she's heard about herself is it
true that you sleep with full hair full
makeup
this is ET Canada presents icons Dolly
Parton
[Music]
she's a Trailblazer a legend and now a
rock star when I sat down with Dolly
Parton in Nashville for an exclusive 101
I just had to get all the tea on her
recent induction into the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame
has it sunk in that you're a rock star
no uh but it's soaking in a little more
I don't know if the ceremony went pink
there and you had Brandi Carlile
supporting you what was it like getting
their support well I love them and I I
just think they're all great all those
gals that were on the show that not Pat
Benatar and Linux and and then of course
Brandy and pink and all the others that
were there it was just great to be in
that house with all those great talented
people and for them to accept me and
kind of make me feel welcome like I was
deserved none of it whether I am or not
I figure if I'm gonna be in the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame
I'm gonna have to earn it
[Applause]
my husband had always told me I should
do a rock album because he is a huge I
mean heavy metal Rock and roller and so
I thought well maybe I will someday but
then when they wanted to induct me into
the Hall of Fame and I didn't think I
deserved it then when they put me in
anyway I thought well I'm going to not
waste this time and to do a real rock
and roll album a true rock and roll not
country at all with rock musicians rock
singers everything you know I wrote with
Kent Wells who actually produced the
album we wrote A Few Originals together
and then I wrote some on my own so we're
going to have some classic singers and
some classic songs and some originals
and I'm calling it rockstar I thought
why not of course because I'm a rock
star though you are a rock star now on
that title but I'm gonna I'm gonna take
advantage of of the timing well send
your thanks to Dolly's other half Carl
Dean for her upcoming rock album while
Carl chooses to stay out of the
spotlight the two have been married
since May 30th 19 66 is there any artist
that Carl is extremely excited that you
are working with well he loves all the
songs and I haven't told him yet who
I'll go into perfectly have on it I
don't even know myself who all is going
to be on it but he'll love it I'm doing
so many of his favorite songs on the
album so I'll play it to him when it's
all done I'm sure people ask you this
all the time but is there a staple
answer for how you guys have lasted so
long 56 years well we love each other we
respect each other we both have a warped
sense of humor and I think humor
honestly I think that is one of the best
things when you're married like that
because even when you have a problem if
you have a great sense of humor rather
than going that way and you know if you
say something you can't take back that's
gonna so we we usually have some crazy
way of getting out of it but I like him
and people say how did it last so long I
say I stay gone
there's a lot to be said about that we
misses each other's face all the time
and we don't he's not in the business so
we have different interests but yet we
have the things we love to do together
so it was meant to be I think he was the
one I was supposed to have and vice
versa is there any artists right now
that you are very impressed by that you
feel are really forging their own path
Brandi Carlile I think it's great she's
like me she kind of crosses all bridges
she's just such a great writer such a
great gal such a beautiful singer too so
I'm very impressed with what she's doing
she's a great producer so she's very uh
very talented Talon is something dolly
is familiar with releasing Dolly Parton
diamonds and rhinestones the greatest
hits collection you just released your
greatest hits album that's exciting well
I've had several Greatest Hits yeah but
this one is the ultra because it's got a
lot of the big songs but a lot of new
songs a lot of stuff to people in my
heart before things that they say were
held in the can meaning on the chef
stuff you record and then also putting
things like Duets like with Kenny and a
lot of things that that are really from
other albums and stuff so it's a really
uh good album I'm proud of that of
course one song featured on the album is
Dolly's 1980s hits nine to five
living
[Music]
here
[Music]
it's the song that became an Anthem for
workers everywhere the title track for
the Beloved 80s movie nine to five
nabbed an Oscar Nom and earned four
Grammy Noms taking home two Awards
reaching number one on the country hot
and adult contemporary Billboard charts
in 1981 it's one of the only songs to
feature the clacking of a typewriter
another iconic hit for Dolly Jolene
Jolene
[Music]
released October 15 1973 Jolene was the
first single off Dolly's 13th solo
studio album and get this the song was
inspired by a bank teller who flirted
with Dolly's husband Carl
your voice
[Music]
in 2004 Jolene was ranked 217 on Rolling
Stones list of the 500 Greatest Songs of
all time but don't worry the list was
revised in 2021 and Jolene moved up to
the 63rd spot
again he's the only one for me Jolie
while the song didn't win a Grammy in
1975 in 2017 Pentatonix take on Jolene
featuring Dolly did take home the Grammy
for Best country duo group performance
actually I can never get enough of that
song it's just one of those songs that
everybody you can't forget it
Jolene how hard can that be learned but
it's just a fun little song that
everybody kind of relates to the story
there's either there's always a Jolene
out there or a Joe Lane somebody that's
trying to steal your partner or that you
feel like somebody's prettier than you
or this and that so I think people
relate to the message but it's just a
fun flowing song it's the most recorded
song that I've ever written wow I mean
it's been recorded worldwide since I've
recorded in I think 72 400 and sometimes
by different bands around the country so
goodness that's a lot well when you hit
Legend status the way you have there are
certain myths that pop up that seem to
follow artists around so I wanted to do
a little segment we call Dolly do or
Dolly don't and bust some of these myths
you ready okay is it true that you sleep
with full hair full makeup most nights
when you're on the road
well I don't I always wear my makeup and
I always if I don't have my own hair
fixed I have a wig on a lampshade or
something because you never know when
you're gonna have to exit a building and
it's like when I live in it when I live
in L.A I have a place out there and
there's always earthquakes and others
and you know you're always thrown out in
the streets and TV cameras and all you
gotta be ready yeah I think it doesn't
matter when you clean your face as long
as you clean it in a 24-hour period so I
usually sleep in my makeup and then I
get up and clean my face put it on again
yeah so I try to stay everybody
just in case I love this about you and
my husband likes it too he does yeah he
likes it better than going to bed with a
shower cap and clear seal on my face at
least I look good you've been married
for 56 years this is what works and I
approve
okay is it true that you love tattoos
and that you're covered in them under
your clothes I have a few tattoos
they're not for the sake of tattoos
although I enjoy seeing them because
they're past tense but I have a tendency
Scar and my scars you know I'm so fair
and if I uh if I have something that I
just feel like I'd rather not look at
that scar then I'll dress it up a little
bit so yeah it's true I have some
tattoos okay I love that is it true that
you have an entire room dedicated to
your wigs and hair pieces uh well I have
a closet that has shelves yeah and my
foreclosed hair and makeup it's really
just a room for that type of stuff but
I'm always on I'm always changing
clothes every day you know so yeah I
have I have areas in any house that I'm
in and I carry like I carry wig trunks
on the road I have trunks made that
really carry like three to three to five
rigs that you have if you're doing shows
it's just so handy yeah and you know
just trying to do my own hair that much
that high that I used to do it years ago
before the Rings and it's just not all I
know healthy plus I'm too busy to sit
and do that you are busy yeah so this
works I'm too fidgety too yeah
I appreciate that what's one of the
wildest rumors that you've heard about
yourself oh heavens I've heard
everything so I don't I don't think
there's anything I haven't I think there
was one time
in inquire magazine that my boobs were
so heavy that it that they had broken my
back down and that I couldn't get up and
I was going to be crippled for the rest
of my life or something like that and I
thought well they are big and they are
heavy but I can still get around with it
I'm doing all right my back's okay my
back's all right if I had a back problem
I don't think it's because
[Music]
you have to love how honest she is okay
after the break we're getting in the
holiday spirit with some of the Stars
making Dolly's nice list from Jimmy
Fallon to Willie Nelson and Miley Cyrus
plus what icon has Dolly sang this stay
tuned
she can out sing me so bad though or so
good I will really have trouble keeping
up with her vocals
welcome back with all the lights and
Decor I'm definitely getting into the
holiday spirit here at JW Marriott the
Rosso Muskoka now with a Christmas album
and a holiday special under her belts we
all know Dolly Parton loves this time of
year so when fans suggested she was the
new queen of Christmas dolly was quick
to say she would be second to fellow
icon Mariah Carey well Mariah responded
saying Dolly let's settle this one you
are the queen of everything the queen of
the world the queen of Christmas the
queen of mine love you to which Dolly
replied I'll Always Love You So does
that mean we could see a new holiday
duet
[Music]
would you ever do a Christmas
collaboration with Mariah Carey I love
Mariah Carey she can out sing me so bad
though or so good I would really have
trouble keeping up with her vocally
because I think she's spectacular what
they call it queen of Christmas right
they called me that and I said no I'll
be miss Christmas sir Mrs Christmas or
something else Christmas right who knows
Never Say Never well Mariah remains on
the wish list Dolly's latest Christmas
special Dolly Parton's Mountain Magic
Christmas sees her duetting with some of
today's hottest stars including Jimmy
Allen Billy Ray Cyrus Willie Nelson and
Jimmy Fallon
[Music]
we had some fun some comedy and we had a
great little song we did so it was fun
and we had some great actors playing the
parts because it's a show within a show
showing a house a show is put together I
felt that that would be entertaining for
the bands and the people that have you
know put it all together when you call
up people to be a part of projects like
this do you ever hear no from people or
is it always a yes I'll do anything
Dolly Parton says uh well usually it's a
yes if they can work it out with a
schedule and I would go out of my way
for any of them as well that's what you
do in this business because I I don't
like asking people to do things I feel
real funny about that in my life I hate
asking people for things but in this
case you know like a lot of times there
was a couple of them called up and said
if you want me to be on the show I will
even Dolly's goddaughter Miley Cyrus
appears in the special and on Dolly's
Christmas album a holly Dolly Christmas
[Music]
from above we're also co-hosting New
Year's Eve with Miley Cyrus Oh I know
that's going to be fun we talked about
that when she was one of the guests yeah
so we talked about what we'd wear I said
you be you and I'll be me and we're
gonna do some skids we're going to do
some hosting we're going to do some
songs so it should be fun I'm sure we're
going to wing a whole lot of it which is
going to be the most fun how nice is it
for you seeing all the successes she's
had she's like me you know be true to
yourself it doesn't matter what other
people say if you worry too much about
things you don't get a lot done what is
one of your favorite holiday traditions
at home
well I love to do what every family
loves to do if you are a family you love
to get with family you love to eat your
favorite foods I cook more like Mama
than any of them everybody says because
I still cook with grease and butter and
things that make stuff taste good and my
sisters they try to live a little
healthier but they can still manage to
make you know when I say if you're
cooking Mama's food you got to cook it
like Muppets and if you ain't going to
I'm cooking it right yeah we all bring
something to the table but we love
getting together singing and tell
stories and have the kids you know have
the presents and my husband's family and
my family and then I live in Nashville
my big part of my family lives in East
Tennessee so we gotta travel around some
to have Christmas with everybody but
that's half the fun between Christmas
and New Year's we get it all in yeah I
love that would your husband Carl say
that you were on the naughty or nice
list this year uh I think damn I was a
little of both
I'm gonna let Santa decide on that one
that's good is coral on the nice or
naughty list yeah both perfect yeah
that's why we've lasted so long we're
just naughty enough to be entertaining
and nice enough to make it last yeah
seriously Dolly and Carl are
relationship goals another relationship
goal Dolly's friendship with Jane Fonda
yeah the icon opens up about their four
decade long packs after the break and
later Dolly spills all in our star
confession who is the most famous person
in your phone and what's the last thing
you called or texted them about uh
hahaha
[Music]
welcome back to ET Canada presents icons
Dolly Parton I'm here with Chef chip
wrong looking forward to this delicious
dinner at JW Marriott the Rosso Muskoka
now Dolly Parton's been known to rock a
looker too we're talking lots of
sparkles bold colors and big hair
you have sported so many iconic looks
over the years so I wanted to show you a
couple of your iconic looks and get your
feedback on them so this is a fit check
so of course this is the infamous
Playboy photo shoot did you know that
this is going to be such an icon no of
course not you never really know what's
going to happen in your career and you
hope you do well you hope you do good
but I just remember when they asked me
to do that I said I would not do a
spread if you're part of the expression
right uh you know I never you know I
didn't want to do that I said I'll do a
interview and I'll do a cover if you
really want me to and I did that and I
think it's funny I look at it I was just
a little little chunky little thing
that's so good I love everything about
it okay this is the premiere of nine to
five back in 1980 yeah with Jane Fonda
Lily Tomlin here and then of course you
three again at The Primetime Emmy Awards
what has this friendship meant to you I
had such a good time
you know we should do that more often it
has made the world to me as I hope it
has to them it was great us working
together that was my first movie we got
to be friends enjoyed working together
we're all different but we're all
professional you know we all know who we
are and what we are and they know me
well enough to know you know I I'm just
going to be me whatever that is and and
we're all like that but I've stayed in
touch with them Through The Years and
love them both to death we help each
other with our Charities and different
things through the years in September
Jane revealed she was diagnosed with
Non-Hodgkin's lymphoma and had begun
chemotherapy treatments how important is
it to be super uh supportive of Jane
Fonda with everything that she's going
through right now as well I'll stay in
touch with her and she says she's doing
good she says she's responding well to
the treatments and so uh yeah that was a
scary thing when I heard that but yeah
she's a tough little thing though you
know she's in good shape you know how
she's taking care of herself through the
years so I imagine some of that's paying
off now hopefully absolutely but she's
like me you know we're like I said tough
old birds and I say old lovingly because
we're not spring chickens anymore but
we're not sprung yet either
I love that okay and last photo youth
the Grammy Awards with Casey Musgraves
and Katy Perry Oh yeah well that was
great I mean that whole thing like when
they do those tributes and have all
those great girls come out and sing with
me and do whatever it's just such a
overwhelming feeling to think that I'm
still relevant to the younger generation
there is something I've done has you
know inspired them so that makes me feel
good I feel like a good older sister but
good advice
ET Canada wants to warm up your winter
with the hottest most in-demand star of
the Season join me for an exclusive sit
down with
the Sun
fly away to the islands of the Bahamas
with ET Canada and turn up the sunshine
with a four-part series on the food
culture beaches and people get the
inside scoop on one of Canada's favorite
sand and winter travel destinations only
on ET Canada
[Music]
welcome back to the fabulous JW Marriott
the Rosso Muskoka now Dolly Parton has
had quite the career she's broken
barriers in country music earned a spot
in the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame and
continues to make chart-topping music
six decades into her career but there's
a few things we don't know about Dolly
so it's only fitting we play a few
rounds of star confessions
quick game called confessions we played
this with Ed Sheeran John Legend pink
favorites comfort food all potatoes oh I
love that no doubt ever ever doubt I've
ever fallen off of has been because of a
potato mashed or french fry or something
to do with the potato I love that starch
who is the most famous person in your
phone and what's the last thing you
called or texted them about
uh I don't know that many famous people
in my phone and I don't text so I just
call them up if I need something perfect
yeah
uh what is a quirk that drives your
friends or family a little bonkers I
don't know oh they don't tell me
to ask I'm so used to talking I never
know when to quit but I talk a lot
because I got a lot to say
and I for one will always be willing to
listen I still can't believe I got to
sit down with Dolly Parton definitely a
career highlight for me well thank you
so much for watching and thanks to our
friends at JW Marriott the Rosso Muskoka
for hosting us we're going to leave you
now with Dolly's hits nine to five be
safe be well
[Music]
[Music]